so here we go for the next 10 minutes
we're gonna write a joke with AJ
Wilkerson using the word Temple the word
of the day we do this every Wednesday on
our YouTube channel and we do this
exercise every day in our Facebook group
as well
but for today the word of the day is
Temple
10 minutes on the clock
drum roll
let us begin
all right
so usually what I like to do
is um I like brainstorm initially like
different things that's what I like
doing too I immediately I play like that
word association game yeah you know so
I'm like okay Temple Shirley Temple
you know and I was like Shirley Temple
that's a person a drink and a thing
oh yeah good point yeah so already that
can be remixed into a joke between
Shirley Temple the drink or Shirley
Temple the person
yeah also there's like the play on words
like Shirley and Shirley
if that makes sense yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so just like just going rule of Threes
with that I'm thinking something along
the lines of like uh
like you like a rule of Threes like a
blank blank and then blank
okay and surely surely surely yeah
like talk about like a difference in
time right
like we're both 80s babies right yeah
yeah yeah
so when we were kid like when we were
kids
like our parents knew who Shirley Temple
was or they had a Shirley Temple and now
in 2022 if somebody says Shirley Temple
it's like where they would
you know aim if they were gonna commit
suicide surely yeah the Temple of your
head yeah
your body is a temple as well yeah this
is but that also that were that quick
word association is why comedians go to
dark jokes first yeah
he was like yeah let's not try
Snapchat in the same joke Let's cross
that one out oh yeah you Dove right in
on that one we're like Shirley Temple
suicide that's the clear Association
there yeah
so Shirley Temple is also
um it's a non-alcoholic drink right
right
so there could be something with um
maybe her being underaged or maybe now
Shirley Temple the actor became an
alcoholic and how she drinks Shirley
temples
um Shirley Temple also uh like she was
in several silent movies right I know
she also like like did like acting like
once like actual like audio was included
but she also did some like silent movies
right oh I don't know yeah I don't know
that much about her
yeah you're not say but um
what else what else can we um
is there anything else we can think of I
usually like to brainstorm for like five
minutes and then try to write something
in five minutes so is there anything
else that comes to mind I wrote Body
Temple oh like the old like your body is
a temple yeah
yeah I wrote that one yeah body's a
temple temple of the head
um I guess Temple of Doom was that the
Nickelodeon show
no that was hidden temple Temple of Doom
was Indiana Jones oh hidden temple okay
um and Tim Pole
Shirley Temple was never a silent movie
star says Bobby oh okay
Victoria said Shirley Temple Black and
she became an ambassador
I don't know it'd become an ambassador
Temple of Zeus okay uh-huh
Temple body is a temple so and I think
body is a temple
healthy
oh so that could be a remix there as
well of like body is a temple people
assume that means you like take care of
your body
but maybe there's a remix to where it's
um
it's like that it's you treat like an
actual Temple so
an actual Temple
what would be an actual temp if that
makes me think of like my body is a
temple literally there's organs and
blood everywhere yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so you take it like literally oh also
also I'm autistic so Temple Grandin
Temple Grandin yeah who's that
that's like the uh the like the mother
of like modern autism really yeah she
does like TED talks and stuff about it
she like she like redesigned like a
bunch of like agricultural stuff
whoa how cool
uh Temple College is another one as well
oh yeah that I think Bill Cosby is known
for but um
maybe not good for the brand anymore
um that goes with the drink thing yeah
and mainly surely like s-u-r
-e-l
uh
Shirley Temple oh that's fun okay
Shirley Temple
[Music]
all right I like that so
we kind of a few things swirling around
here in the last
for
people are spitting out a lot of Shirley
Temple facts this is hilarious
so with four we really sparked some
interest here yeah spark speaking of
which
spark AJ sparked
um
so with four minutes left here let's try
to put together a joke here I I really
like
our remix of like the Shirley Temple and
like the drink and the actor
and there may be a play in there with
like Cosby going to Temple University or
something
um but uh what what are you feeling here
we brainstormed a few things what are
you feeling
I dig the Shirley Temple thing and this
is one of those like this is what I love
right 10 for right because in 10 minutes
that like a Shirley Temple joke like a
like a rule of three joke or like a
longer bit is gonna be too like complex
to work out I think
so my brain is literally going like
abandon that and going back to like that
body is a temple okay
Okay cool so I I think I hit like so in
my head I would set aside like the
Shirley Temple joke because that's
something I would like come back to like
after right 10 is over and then I'd be
like okay now how can I turn this into
like a real a real bit or something that
I would use on stage right yeah yeah
yeah right Tim's good to get ideas out
as well and then go back and revisit
them yeah so I actually I think I said
it out loud on accident and so that's
probably like the joke I would go back
and like look at and be like uh you know
like my body is a temple
um
so like yes so it could be like I like
to treat my body like a temple only care
for it on Sundays or like
um
so it's kind of like if body is a temple
then now where's like the an event
diagram where's the overlap between the
two you know or like
yeah I like to let people come inside it
on Sundays
oh yeah yeah
people come inside on Sundays
ah what else do people do with temples
temples are outdated right but my body
is the temple I change the sign weekly
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah we're getting some good um temples
yeah I think though the the one uh uh
about like the
like because I when I think of Temple I
think of like
sacrifice right you know what I mean
uh-huh
so that's kind of where I I think I'm
going back to I'm circling back to that
one
come inside and dance around
said Victoria
temple in the day party at night
um
yeah it could be
um in a temple people pray
um
so maybe I like to treat my body like a
temple so I'm I I get I came up with uh
my body as a temple I don't pay taxes on
what it earns and there's blood and body
parts everywhere our blood and organs
everywhere
oh I like okay or switch it around like
my body is a temple there's blood and
organs everywhere and I don't pay taxes
on what it makes
yeah I like um the the taxes yeah let's
try to tighten it up so my body is a
temple
I don't pay taxes it's a tax write-off
um
full of sin repent
uh Lord's Supper
communion
uh relics outdated old
stones
service preacher
oh that's actually perfect my body is
the temple I don't pay taxes and it's
full of hypocrisy
boom
there it is
there it is there it is there it is
[Applause]
oh and that okay his mom said um my body
is a temple but the temple is falling
apart and just caught fire
foreign
nice okay so my body is a temple what
did you say my body is a temple
it doesn't pay taxes and it's falling
apart
uh
uh oh I said uh full of hypocrisy
oh okay yeah so it's
it doesn't pay taxes and it's full of
hypocrisy yep cool
I like that
yeah but and see that is one of those
things like you the more you start
thinking about it you're like oh there's
like three or four of these in a row
that we've thought of that if you wanted
to turn it into a bit those are very
solid tags yeah exactly you know what I
mean yeah yeah for sure of right ten
fours it makes you really like okay how
do I condense this as much as possible
and then you can take something be like
oh what I thought was a joke is actually
a tag for something that could actually
go somewhere else
yeah exactly and you find new
connections and stuff like it's all
it's all productive writing even like
you'll be surprised I think a lot of the
times
people
convince themselves not to write because
they over complicate that it has to be
this magical thing every single time but
it's literally like a lot of just
incremental writing that then over time
accumulates into some ideas and bits and
things but most of writing is literally
just like getting ideas out of your head
and onto the page and then over time
they kind of come together I think that
is like the the coolest thing about
right 10 and like the word of the day
concept is like like you're right
everyone expects like oh I'm gonna sit
down right and it's going to be magic
and it's almost never magic right but
you can't like Force lightning to strike
but if you sit down to right like you're
holding a lightning rod
you know what I mean like that word
could be the one thing like oh lightning
struck I'm already holding the pencil
you know what I mean I'm already trying
right exactly
but yeah the hardest part is getting
over that hump of like okay I'm writing
I grabbed like a back of a coloring
sheet page and a crayon and that's all
it took
I love that you are riding with that
that is so good
I'm riding with a um it's a Bic Atlantis
it's a blue big Atlantis black crayon
dog on the back of a Jurassic Park
coloring
oh that's great there are there are no
rules
yeah there are exactly exactly
I'm and I'm writing your joke now I'm
putting it in the Facebook group
because my body as a temple it doesn't
pay taxes and it's full of hypocrisy yes
nice
if I knew how to spell hypocrisy
my liberal arts degree did not teach me
that's the great thing about comedy is
it doesn't have to be spelled right
because you speak it yes good point my
friend good point
yay that was dope this is our first time
doing that I appreciate that that's
great
oh we got um
um
Victoria said it takes donations oh
that's good
oh I like
yeah that's a good one
well let's um
my body is a temple there's the
dedicated visitors entrance
yeah yeah yeah
back door I don't know why I took it
there but um
yeah now that now that we get the
analogy going we can see a lot of
parallels between body and tempting yeah
let's see what some other peeps wrote
here
um so the word that is Temple so if you
haven't do
um post your joke here in the live chat
we're gonna read it
live on the ad looks like over in our
first joke I'm seeing is from Joyce
Lyles
her joke is my body is the temple of God
just like my house it needs some repairs
all right all right all right very nice
Joyce
I feel like we're gonna have a lot of
bodies Temple jokes perhaps because that
is basically like with a joke I mean the
goal is to find
how can I Remix or reinterpret or
misdirect this common concept so body is
a temple there's some clear misdirects
you can create there same thing with
Shirley Temple so it's kind of like
especially in this exercise it's like
what's most obvious and exciting to you
and how can you turn into a joke in 10
minutes so
we'll see though that's just my theory
on there's going to be a lot